okay a couple things one there's some
evidence that
cancer spreads less fast
if you don't eat because you don't feed
it glucose same with if you're on a
ketogenic diet
there's evidence that you can
potentially affect
cancer cells because a lot of them
consume glucose
okay are they not cancer cells that are
fed by ketone bodies though
because i because i've i
i'm not 100 sure that's why i'm asking
because i'm pretty sure that there's
a straw man argument where people are
are picking up their
their kind of elements they go oh well
cancer cells are fed by glucose but then
someone else was like okay but there are
other ones that are fed by ketone bodies
and honestly honestly that's so
far out of my area of expertise that i'm
not comfortable talking about it
like i i don't know from from what i've
seen i have seen case studies for people
on ketogenic diets with it
halting or slowing tumor progression
i've seen case studies so you can
take that information and do whatever
with it
um but specifically for jason fung the
reason i started looking into him was
because i was playing around with my
diet i was like
you know first first i was shocked that
i didn't need grains to survive because
i thought that you needed grains to
survive
i was at that point then then
i was like this paleo diet this is what
fixed me this is the answer
and then it stopped working and i went
on a carnivore diet and i was like what
the hell like i can survive off of meat
for an extended period of time that's
[ __ ] like so that just blew my mind so
i had my mind blown multiple times
starting with the medical system isn't
helping me oh my god
i can use diet to help my symptoms oh my
god i don't need to eat grains oh my god
i don't need to eat plants
right so it's just like so then i just
lost faith in absolutely everything i
ever knew
really it was like the government does
anyone know what they're talking about
is anything real anymore
um and then i started i'd heard about
fasting and i'd seen some seriously
extreme fasting and i was like meh okay
i'll give that a shot because
i don't know that's weird that people
can do that
so i did some extended fasts and i did a
couple of long fasts
just to see what would happen
realistically
um and how i felt on the fasts led me to
jason fung because you do i mean it's
skyr
it's pretty obvious you don't eat for a
while um
i didn't feel that bad not eating which
was surprising if i
if i kept my electrolytes up but you
you're completely full of adrenaline
because your body's like go eat so
your adrenaline your your adrenaline
goes up but it was like i could
see better i could think faster and i'm
sure part of that is to encourage you to
go eat
if you're not eating but so i started
looking into him that way and
i don't think well i like him
that's why i had him on my podcast have
you read his book
uh no the obesity code uh the thing is
that
like you say the the conversations are
being had with such complex topics that
nor you nor i nor many people uh
are actually qualified on i'm pretty
sure his doctorate was from kidney
is a kidney specialist um
but he started looking into kidney
disease because he was treating
diabetics and he was treating diabetics
by implementing fasting
however with these high level kind of
debates that are going on
it you've it's very easy to create straw
man arguments
at this top level because not many
people are going to be able to go
it doesn't sound right they just take it
as fact you know you're like
cancer cells tumor glucose people like
[ __ ] it all make sense
you know they sit back they're like oh
my god and it's so easy to convert these
people
because you know people are now trying
to debunk all the other systems jason
fung is again someone saying that
cutting calories
won't help you lose weight and you know
i was like whoa you've got a bit carried
away uncle
you know hold on a second you might have
had you might have had some stellar work
in this field but you've kind of
overstepped it
and to me that's fair it just seems that
you know
if he's gonna i know exactly what he's
doing he's trying to debunk the calorie
and calorie out model
and there's a lot of support behind him
for that but there's a lot of support
behind
a lot of movements that aren't great and
it's
very easy for me to see his narrative
with these things and
if he's going to have a narrative that
defies thermodynamics
you know if he's going to have a
narrative that defies [ __ ] physics
where else am i going to put his moral
compass you know what i mean so
hold on mate you've literally just gone
on a video with someone who's got
over a million followers and spoken
openly about how reducing calories is
you know not a way to lose weight and
that
people have got hormonal issues or
whatever objectively
making these insinuations and claims
excuse to me like if he's going to do it
this side i just can't imagine that he
wouldn't do it somewhere else
and ultimately the bottom line here is
book sales the bottom line here is
you know having this movement that goes
against the grain and
as soon as i see a [ __ ] in someone's
armor in one place
i can't credit the model
and for that reason it is one of those
things where
we'll we will agree to disagree on that
and i think that
it's probably as well because we're
button heads on things and you know if
he's helping people and if fasting is
helping those people
it that's fine and again it's not like a
war where
i have to conquer jason fung we're just
two people that
should be allowed to butt heads on
things because ultimately his team are
fasting hungry people that can't sleep
because their adrenals are [ __ ]
firing
you do you guys if you like that then
you [ __ ] do that
but then i've got my my camper people
over here they're like [ __ ] out i
lost six pounds in the last three weeks
eating cereal every
day you know what i mean so like we have
our camps we have our people
and you know even you know trish from
[ __ ] norfolk she's over there going
i had [ __ ] you know gluten every day
and i feel better because i've lost 15
kilograms and
it you know oh james my husband started
[ __ ] me again you know and i've
i've had unhealthy foods every day so
like we we always have these like
different camps we're in
but you know i never try and attack
people based on uh
who they are what they're doing just
when they say things that aren't true
i'm not well that's not right mate you
know i get what you're doing i get what
you're saying
but [ __ ] don't get too carried away
and when people are left with these big
echo chambers
you know to say these things without
repercussions um
it makes it easier for people to keep
taken and taken and taken
yeah well that's part of the reason i
love social media and that's part of the
reason why we've been
i think dad in particular has been so up
in arms about freedom of speech
because you have to be able to see
everybody
right so if you have somebody saying
things and you don't agree with them you
need to be able to
you should be allowed to tell people why
you don't agree
and then other people should be able to
listen to that and and decide
who to agree with i i try and tell
everybody who's watching me
like i know that i have i i i'm
extremely biased
at the moment and that's because of the
experience i had with medical system and
so
and like i said my mind was blown so
many times that now i'm like
literally anything is possible like i'm
gonna be into
astrology soon it's gonna happen one day
like anything is possible
so i'm i'm totally aware of that um
and it's a problem but people should
just like people have to research
themselves they and they should look at
and if they're in an echo chamber like
if they're if everyone around them
agrees with them all the time
then they're in an echo chamber and they
should see what people outside of that
echo chamber are saying
otherwise they're going to end up like
what happened to me with oh i thought
one thing and it was completely wrong oh
i thought another thing and it was
completely wrong and then
your world view just falls apart so you
have to make sure
that you're seeing everything around you
and you're not too
interested in one idea or in an echo
chamber